[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
mitri sie geben schönen guten abend
ihnen alle wir hoffen sie sind gut durch
den tag gekommen und für den sport
wieder mit dabei ihr kristin otto hallo
und guten dann blicken wir gemeinsam auf
die wichtigsten themen an diesem
donnerstag hier sind einige
trauer und entsetzen in norwegen ein
mann tötet mit pfeil und bogen fünf
menschen die polizei geht von
terrorismus aus
weniger wachstum der
wirtschaftsaufschwung in deutschland
fällt wohl erst mal deutlich geringer
aus als erwartet und
vierte corona welle auf der
intensivstation ärzte und pflegekräfte
zwischen wut und erschöpfung manche
geben auf
fassungslosigkeit und entsetzen über
einen terrorakt in norwegen nachdem
gestern abend noch vieles unklar war
werden nun immer mehr details bekannt
getroffen hat es die stadt kongsberg
südwestlich der hauptstadt oslo gestern
abend ist dort ein angreifer mit pfeil
und bogen bewaffnet durch die innenstadt
gezogen hat offenbar wahllos auf
menschen geschossen fünf hat er dabei
getötet drei verletzt das motiv könnte
in eine islamistische richtung hinweisen
class thomsen über das was bislang
bekannt ist
ist dies wirklich was ihr wollt in einer
videobotschaft im internet verkündet der
mutmaßliche attentäter von kongsberg
2017 er sei zum islam übergetreten und
er spreche eine war
gestern abend könnte der 37-jährige snb
nun seine warnung war gemacht haben seit
langem lebt der däne norwegen seit
langem soll er etwa mit gewalttätigen
auftretenden polizeibekannt sein und er
fiel auf mit einer möglichen
radikalisierungen zum islamismus ein man
bewege sich durch die stadt und schießen
mit pfeil und bogen auf menschen so die
meldung bei der polizei kurz nach 18 uhr
eine halbe stunde später wird er
festgenommen zuvor hatte er auch die
beamten beschossen
die polizei war zwar schon im einsatz
aber spezialeinheiten kam erst nach der
festnahme
wahrscheinlich starben die fünf opfer so
als der einsatz der norwegen umgeworfen
regulären beamten schon lief augenzeugen
an denen ein mann mit freiem rücken
vorbei hatte dachten an einen scherz
er lief herum und warnte alle dass sie
sich in sicherheit bringen soll
vier frauen und ein mann im alter
zwischen 50 und 70 werden getötet ob
wahllos oder gezielt ist unklar für den
neuen ministerpräsidenten von norwegen
anders dürre seit dem mittag erste mahnt
ein trauriger anlass sein erstes regnet
meine gedanken sind bei den betroffenen
bei den angehörigen und familien einen
verängstigten
anders als schutz waffen gelten pfeil
und bogen norwegen wie in deutschland
als sport utensilien und nicht als
waffen jedermann kann sie problemlos
erwerben
für uns bei oslo ist hannah hebestreit
hannah des landes aufgewühlt von terror
ist die rede was löst die tat in
norwegen aus
die menschen hier sind natürlich sehr
betroffen man fühlt sich als bewohner
eines der friedlichen landes als als
menschen in einer idylle in einer der
heilen welt aber die bilder von gäste
die wir eben auch in dem beitrag gesehen
haben von bränden den menschen die um
ihr leben laufen einer buchstäblich mit
einem pfeil in dem rücken der andere
gewarnt hat das alles erinnert auch
viele in norwegen an den
rechtsextremistischen terrorist anders
breivik dessen tat man am zehnten
jahrestag im juli gefeiert hat und
dessen opfer man auch gedacht hat jetzt
also kongsberg die polizei hat seit
damals sehr viel gelernt hat umfassend
und schnell reagiert trotzdem muss sie
sich fragen stellen lassen man kannte
den täter man hat ihn auf dem radar wann
wusste von seiner gewaltbereitschaft
trotzdem konnte er fünf leute umbringen
und auch für die neue regierung ist das
heute kein guter start viele die jetzt
in anderen würden sind haben vor zehn
jahren schon mit dem terror zu tun
gehabt norwegen stellt heute fest die
idylle das ist ein trugschluss vielen
dank herr hebestreit nach norwegen
kein geheimnis je besser die wirtschaft
läuft desto besser geht es auch uns die
korona pandemie und weltweite
lieferschwierigkeiten belasten gerade
das wachstum insofern wurde mit spannung
die neueste prognose der
wirtschaftsforscher erwartet kurz
zusammengefasst lässt sich sagen
schlechter als erhofft aber es gibt
licht
am ende des tunnels schauen wir jetzt
gemeinsam auf die entwicklung mit dem
ausbruch von corona da war die deutsche
wirtschaft im vergangenen jahr ins minus
gerutscht und zwar deutlich das sehen
wir hier für dieses jahr rechneten die
experten eigentlich mit einem wachstum
von 3,7 prozent jetzt gehen sie nur noch
von 2,4 prozent aus deutlich besser
laufen soll es dann aber im nächsten
jahr mit 4,8 prozent wachstum details
von lars bohnsack ihr bericht enthält
licht und schatten fünf
wirtschaftsinstitute müssen ihre
prognose für dieses jahr deutlich nach
unten korrigieren zum einen werden
kontakt intensive dienstleistungen
weiter beeinträchtigt die befinden sich
noch nicht auf normalniveau zum anderen
sind internationale lieferketten
gestört das sind zum teil auch noch
folgewirkungen der pandemie noch also
bremsen lieferprobleme den aufschwung so
kann opel in eisenach wegen fehlender
elektronikteile nicht produzieren
besserung ist erst nächstes jahr in
sicht ähnlich bei der inflationsrate
steigen die verbraucherpreise in diesem
jahr noch um drei prozent ist 2023 nur
noch mit 1,7 prozent zu rechnen wir
gehen aber davon aus dass zb impulse von
rohstoffpreisen langsam auslaufen werden
und dass sich in dem maße dann auch die
inflationsraten wieder in richtung ihr
auf ihre niedrigeren langjährigen
mittelwerte
zurückbewegen gute aussichten für eine
kommende regierung eigentlich es brauche
aber eine deutlich schnellere
digitalisierung und mehr erneuerbare
energien wie 50 unternehmer und
wissenschaftler fordern klima und
umweltpolitik kann nicht mehr nur aus
dem umweltministerium heraus
vorangebracht werden deswegen muss
natürlich der klimaschutz in verbindung
mit der digitalen transformation
chefsache werden das muss vom kanzleramt
vorangebracht werden alle ressorts
müssen diese richtung arbeiten sonst
haben wir keine chance diese
anspruchsvolle agenda umzusetzen die
botschaft des tages der aufschwung kommt
aber später als gedacht die künftige
regierung muss dafür allerdings auch die
richtigen weichen stellen
dann schauen wir jetzt zur landespolitik
nach mecklenburg vorpommern
da stehen die zeichen auf umbruch die
spd wechselt nämlich ihren
regierungspartner zumindest sieht es
danach aus die linken sollen es künftig
sein ministerpräsidentin schwesig hatte
nach dem deutlichen spd sieg mit fast 40
prozent jahr freie wahl nicht nur mit
den linken gab es gespräche auch mit fdp
mit grünen und auch mit dem bisherigen
partner der cdu die geht nach 15
gemeinsamen jahren wohl zurück in die
opposition
susanne seidel
es herrscht eine freudige
arbeitsatmosphäre bei den linken sie
bereiten zurzeit die koalitionsgespräche
mit der spd vor und das obwohl sie nur
9,9 prozent der wählerstimmen erhielten
und trotzdem sind wir eine starke truppe
wir haben hervorragend sondiert und wir
werden jetzt weiter gestärkt in die
koalitionsgespräche gehen und dann
hoffen wir dass am ende eine starke rot
rote regierung für ein tolles
mecklenburg vorpommern steht ein rot
rotes bündnis hatte es bereits von 1998
bis 2006 im nordosten gegeben jetzt
laufen in der schweriner staatskanzlei
die vorbereitungen für eine neuauflage
insbesondere weil wir auch hier in den
gesprächen den eindruck hatten dass wir
es hier mit einem sehr verlässlichen
partner zu tun haben was auch das
personal angeht
auch wenn die cdu beim wahlergebnis noch
vor der linken lag bleibt ihr jetzt nur
der gang in die opposition
das lag vor allem daran dass die linken
diesmal politisch und auch inhaltlich
deutlich billiger zu haben waren als die
cdu wir haben gut verhandelt werden
glaube ich ein gutes
sondierungsergebnisse und vor
schließlich hat jetzt diese entscheidung
getroffen das land er nach links zu
führen ein wichtiger punkt bei der
entscheidung schwesigs für rot-rot ist
sicher die unsichere personalsituation
in der cdu nach dem rücktritt des
parteivorsitzenden michael sack bleibt
die führungsfrage in der cdu vorerst
ungeklärt
morgen um 11 sollen die rot roten
koalitionsverhandlungen in schwerin
beginnen
in mecklenburg vorpommern sieht also
nach rot-rot aus in berlin schlägt das
chaos zur abgeordnetenhauswahl weiter
hohe wellen die aufarbeitung die wird
wohl definitiv auch juristisch
stattfinden nicht ausgeschlossen dass es
in einigen beziehung dort zu nur nach
wahlen kommt derweil verkündete spd
wahlsiegerin giffey mit wem sie sich
künftig im senat sieht und die alten
könnten auch die neuen partner sein
stephan merseburger
eigentlich schlägt ihr herz für eine
ampelkoalition durch große teile der
berliner spd sehen das anders sie wollen
nicht mit grünen und fdp sondern weiter
mit grünen und linken regieren
und so muss franziska giffey morgen
koalitionsverhandlungen für rot grün rot
vorbereiten jetzt heißt es die sicht
waren führungsanspruch anmelden es muss
klar sein dass dieses was wir dort tun
auch eine sehr deutliche
sozialdemokratische handschrift trägt
und für mich war es eine gelingens
bedingung dass wir eine verständigung
zum wohnungsneubau bündnis zu einem
klaren kurs in diese richtung auch
hinbekommen dass wir auch einen
vernünftigen weg finden um mit dem
volksentscheid umzugehen über 56 prozent
der berliner haben für deutsche wohnen &
co enteignen gestimmt die linke ist für
vergesellschaftung gv entschieden
dagegen da sind noch echte hindernisse
aus dem weg zu räumen
das ausmaß der pannen und peinlichkeiten
am berliner super wahlsonntag ist noch
größer als befürchtet
2257 wahllokale gab es in 207 also fast
einem zehntel kam es zu
unregelmäßigkeiten wenn ich sage 207
wahllokalen dann ist das natürlich eine
zahlen die uns alle erschrecken muss und
auch ärgern muss in zwei wahlkreisen mit
besonders knappem ausgang will die
landeswahlleitung einspruch erheben wir
sind zu dem schluss gekommen dass sich
die unregelmäßigkeiten in diesen beiden
fällen mandatsrelevanten
gewirkt haben können auch andere
einsprüche werden vorbereitet ob und in
welchem umfang die wahl wiederholt
werden muss entscheidet der
verfassungsgerichtshof in berlin da
scheint also das letzte wort noch nicht
gesprochen zu sein fragen und antworten
zum war chaos in berlin finden sie in
unserer zdf heute auch nochmal
zusammengefasst
es ist ein ambitioniertes ziel das sich
die vereinten nationen da gesetzt haben
den hunger auf der welt bis zum jahr
2030 zu besiegen aber kriege die
klimakrise und nicht zuletzt corona
lassen dieses ziel in weite ferne rücken
und das zeigen auch erschütternde zahlen
der welthungerhilfe etwa
811 millionen menschen hungern weltweit
41 millionen leben sogar am rande einer
hungersnot besonders dramatisch ist die
lage etwa in madagaskar das mit den
folgen der schlimmsten dürre seit 30
jahren kämpft susan von lojewski
kakteen sind alles was den menschen im
süden madagaskars geblieben ist mühsam
picken sie in hartz von den stacheligen
pflanzen es ist nicht viel und es reicht
gerade so zum überleben
der inselstaat erlebt die schlimmste
dürrekatastrophe seit jahrzehnten 1,3
millionen menschen sind von der
hungersnot bedroht
ich schäme mich weil ich meine kinder
nicht ernähren kann wir leben in armut
früher war ich starren konnte ihnen
essen bringen aber jetzt kann ich das
nicht mehr
und wieder einmal sind es die kinder die
besonders zu leiden haben in dieser
mobilen klinik werden sie untersucht und
gewogen wir als 130000 mädchen und
jungen so experten sind akut
unterernährt
es ist sieben mal schlimmer als vor
einem jahr siebenmal mehr kinder sind in
schwierigkeiten
wieso wegen der dürre wir stehen vor der
schlimmsten dürre seit 40 jahren das ist
eine gegend wo die menschen von ihrer
eigenen landwirtschaft
das land aber gibt nichts mehr hier wo
einst der strom an drive los ist jetzt
sand mühsam graben die menschen im boden
um überhaupt noch wasser zu finden oft
müssen sie stundenlang laufen um ihre
kanister zu füllen
es gibt keinen regen mehr keine felder
mehr wegen der dürre ich muss tage lang
gehen ohne essen
madagaskar ist auf dem weg in eine
humanitäre katastrophe
die nächsten ergiebigen regenfälle
sollen frühestens im april nächsten
jahres kommen wenn sie denn kommen
wir blicken nun in den libanon dort ist
die lage kompliziert sie ist
spannungsgeladen es gab heute tote nach
gewaltsamen protesten hintergrund ist
die juristische aufarbeitung der
verheerenden explosion im beiruter hafen
weil sie den leitenden richter für
befangen hält rief die muslimische
hisbollah zu protesten auf dann fielen
offenbar schüsse aus einem christlich
geprägten viertel die gewalt eskalierte
mindestens sechs menschen starben bei
einem hochhausbrand im süden taiwans
sind mindestens 46 menschen ums leben
gekommen weitere 41 wurden verletzt das
feuer brach in einem 13 stöckigen
gebäude in der hafenstadt chaos jung aus
etliche bewohner waren in den oberen
etagen eingeschlossen erst nach mehreren
stunden konnten einsatzkräfte die
flammen unter kontrolle bringen die
brandursache ist noch unklar
schauen wir auf die aktuellen corona
zahlen laut robert koch institut wurden
innerhalb eines tages 12 1382
neuinfektionen registriert das sind 7
138 mehr als vor einer woche außerdem
kamen 72 todesfälle hinzu nur leichte
veränderungen bei der sieben tage
incidents sie steigt auf jetzt
67,0
und hinter all diesen zahlen das darf
man nicht vergessen stehen menschen und
ihre unterschiedlichen geschichten fast
1400 liegen derzeit auf deutschen
intensivstationen dort arbeitende
ärztinnen und ärzte sowie das
pflegepersonal sind nach monaten der
pandemie extrem erschöpft und viele von
ihnen die fragen sich warum haben sich
die patienten nicht impfen lassen
tatsächlich sind die allermeisten
intensivpatienten ungeimpft eva schiller
mit eindrücken aus dem klinikum
stuttgart
die pandemie hat jetzt ein anderes
gesicht auf der kogit intensivstation
des klinikums stuttgart sind fast alle
patienten ungeimpft zwischen 40 und 50
wie dieser mann ohne vorerkrankungen den
jetzt die lungen maschine am leben hält
in ruhigen minuten
lässt denkt man schon darüber nach
warum haben sich nicht mehr impfen
lassen warum ist mir jetzt noch mal in
die vierte warum so viele wie in der
woche zuvor ist eine 36 jährige
gestorben die korona geleugnet hat das
personal hat zwischen mitleid und
unverständnis er lebt davon dass man
mitfühlt dass man einfühlsam ist und
dann erlebt man eine situation sehr
geballt wenn man jetzt hier nachmittag
auf der station ist
das müsste ja eigentlich nicht sein oder
kommt schon manchmal die wut hoch vor
allem wenn man mit leuten spricht die
des rigoros ablehnen doch querdenker
sind die ausnahme die meisten
ungeimpften patienten haben von der
impfkampagne wenig mitbekommen oder
hatten angst vor einer impfung was mich
jetzt so ein bisschen immer ein bisschen
daran gehindert hat na ja das ist ja
noch nicht alles so erforscht und alles
so neu und mal gucken und was gibts
dafür nebenwirkung das war immer so ein
bisschen was ich so verfolgt habe ja
eigentlich blöd aber jetzt weiß ich dass
hätte schon viel früher machen sollen
die familie und viele bekannte sind
nicht geimpft ihr schwerer verlauf
ändert jetzt meinungen druck sei aber
das falsche mittel findet sie druck sei
dringend nötig entgegnet das
klinikpersonal einige pflegekräfte hier
in stuttgart haben gekündigt weil ihnen
die kraft fehlt für diese führte welle
es sind wohl die letzten amtstage von
bundeskanzlerin merkel momentan befindet
sie sich ja auch so eine art
abschiedstour auch heute einen termin
der angenehmeren sorte in spanien ist
sie mit dem renommierten preis karl fünf
ausgezeichnet worden für ihre verdienste
um europa wenig philippe würdigte merkel
als persönlichkeit die ihrer zeit stets
voraus gewesen sei in ihrer dankesrede
merkel zur überwindung von
meinungsverschiedenheiten auf europa
seien nur so stark wie es einig sein
also wir sind uns hier auf jeden fall
einig dass du hübsch port weitermachen
und das muss jetzt sein genau und zuerst
gibt es den spruch mein tennis ist
ziemlich okay sagte alexander zverev
nach seiner überzeugenden vorstellung
beim masters in indian wells gegen den
franzosen gael monfils der olympiasieger
dominierte beide sätze und zog erstmalig
ins viertelfinale ein
20 mal in den letzten 21 spielen konnte
alexander zverev als sieger die
ovationen genießen beeindruckend im
schnellgang mit 6 1 durch satz nummer
eins gelingt ihm nach diesem netzangriff
das vorentscheidende break zum 5 3 im
zweiten
der franzose profis bisher durchaus eine
art angstgegner für zverev drei spiele
drei niederlagen
doch bereits nach einer guten stunde ist
der 6 2 1 6 2 erfolg unter dach und fach
profis verschlägt nach diesem
ungefährdeten achtelfinalsieg gibt es
kaum noch hochkaräter auf dem weg zum
ersten titelgewinn in der kalifornischen
wüste
freude und frust bei den beiden
norddeutschen handball verein in der
champions league während rekordmeister
thw kiel durch das 36 zu 28 gegen zagreb
unbeirrt auf viertelfinal kurs liegt
droht der personell geschwächten sg
flensburg handewitt nach dem 29 37 im
polnischen kelze das vorzeitige aus
fröhliche stimmung und zufriedenheit bei
den fußballerinnen des vfl wolfsburg am
zweiten spieltag der königsklasse
bejubelten sie ihren ersten sieg in
dieser noch jungen saison gegen die
frauen von servette genf mit 15 0
das war klar und deutlich trotz großer
verletzungssorgen der vfl wolfsburg von
beginn an offensiv und schon in der 18
minute mutter belohnung svenja huth
trifft im nachschuss zur führung dann
der doppelpack von tabea war es mut mit
ihm sorgt sie schon vor der pause für
klare verhältnisse was mutter damit in
zwei champions league spiel bereits vier
treffer torreich geht's auch in halbzeit
zwei weiter 51 minute dominik jansen
gelingt reaktion schnell das 40 und
james mit hat dann in der 68 minute viel
zeit liefert offen die wolfsburgerinnen
damit erste ihre gruppe in der
königsklasse ja und heute wollen bayern
münchen und hoffenheim nachziehen bei
den frauen freuen wir uns drauf und
sagen danke christian und wir beide
können ihnen auch sagen dass hoch
philine auf dem weg zu uns ist was das
für das kommende wetter bedeutet katja
honnefer erzählt ihnen gleich meine
einschalt empfehlung lautet 21 45 das
heute journal mit claus kleber wir im 19
uhr heute team sagen danke fürs
zuschauen schön donnerstagabend und
gerne bis morgen um 7
[Musik]
guten abend jetzt kommt bewegung ins
wetter und das liegt an der kaltfront
von tief gerald die zieht nämlich weiter
in richtung mitteleuropa und löst sich
über der mitte deutschlands morgen
einfach auf und dann ist der weg frei
für ein neues hoch philine das uns
schönes ruhiges herbstwetter zum
wochenende bringt heute nacht geht es
erstmal los mit der kaltfront im
nordwesten da nimmt der wind auch
wirklich zu ihr kommt aus südwestlichen
richtungen sonst ist es in deutschland
wolkig in süddeutschland auch mal klar
da bildet sich dann nebel südlich der
donau sinken die temperaturen auf plus 2
bis minus 1 grad dort droht also
bodenfrost im norden bleibt es bei 12
bis 7 grad milder ob morgen liegen die
höchsttemperaturen meist um 14 grad
etwas kühler ist es in den
mittelgebirgen wärmer dagegen am neckar
zum beispiel in stuttgart oder hannover
rhein mit 17 grad die kaltfront der
nacht zieht schon morgen vormittag
weiter nach süden erreicht das sauerland
den harz und berlin dahinter lockern die
wolken schon wieder auf und der wind
dreht von süd west auf nordwest in
süddeutschland gibt es nach nebel am
morgen sonnenschein und das ändert sich
auch am nachmittag nicht die kalte und
löst sich mehr oder weniger in der mitte
auf und am samstag gibt es schönes
wetter am sonntag montag an es in
norddeutschland ein bisschen regnen und
es wird wärmer guten abend